whose couch vita legends of chamberlain
hi
these is our top nine lines for garbage
time it's garbage time mother
so get you know playing asses in the
goddamn game nah Dookie breath I got
that affluenza back to dead coach I got
their 24-hour aids I'm good if I break a
sweat
then I got a shower after the game man
got it
I'm not playing til president Trump stop
spray tanning I'd rather die on my
chicks than get garbage time in defeat
I'm cool don't want to get the 9r Swan
I'm on that entry Reserve pull it on my
groin too hard last night
sorry coach I got a heart murmur I ain't
trying to shoot no squid balls on the
court I'm gonna exercise my First
Amendment right to freedom of cheeks Amy
y'all so not playing mother nobody likes
having a stache messed up with garbage
time minutes yep so the next time you
come tries to play you play yourself my
knee
ahh
[Music]